today we're gonna talk about time
management hacks in law school
there is absolutely no substitute for
hard work in law school but I can
recommend a few things that will save
you a hell of a lot of time to work
smarter instead of harder so stay tuned
so let's talk about time management
hacks for law school things that will
help you save a huge amount of time so
that you can do the things that will
really help on the final exam
and get you better grades at the end of
the semester so we want to cut out all
the busy work possible the first time
saving tip that I would recommend is to
get prior outlines get old outlines that
are specifically tailored for your
professor you can talk to upperclassmen
who have had your professor before or
you can go to outline depot.com outline
depot.com is great i have no affiliation
with them but it's a great website where
if you upload one outline you're allowed
to get a credit to download someone
else's outline and because so many
people have uploaded outlines to their
database odds are they're going to have
a prior outline for your specific
professor in the class that you're
taking so I would recommend getting a
handful of outlines for your specific
professor so that you can use those as a
template to make your own outlines it's
it's no substitute for putting in the
time learning the law but it can provide
a great foundation that you can add or
subtract to it's the beginning of the
process that you can use to save a lot
of time instead of doing it from scratch
by the same token use commercial
outlines and case proofs things like
Emmanuel's for contracts there are
commercial outlines in just about any
class that you can think of they will
save you a huge amount of time in
learning the substantive law and
recently there have been preponderance
of websites and databases out there that
will case brief every single case you
could possibly come across for you it
can save you a huge amount of time we
don't advocate doing any case briefs we
think they're a waste of time
but it's great to look at other case
briefs to provide a foundation before
you read the case it's
great to understand what the general
idea of the case is before you dig into
your case book and read the case
yourself tip number three use Westlaw
Westlaw is great you will use it all the
time in practice either Westlaw or
LexisNexis so you might as well get
familiar with it in law school and one
of the great things you can do is if you
don't want to go the commercial case
brief route things like Quimby for
example you can use Westlaw to look up
the case that your professor wants you
to read even if the case is old Westlaw
has an army of reference attorneys that
summarize every single case you could
just read through the Westhead notes and
get a good idea of what the case is
about and then probably summarizes the
exact rule of law that you're going to
need to learn for the final exam so
don't be afraid to use Westlaw it's not
cheating it's a great way to practice
something that you're going to use all
the time in researching in the real
world tip number four outlined from day
one this is controversial a lot of
people wait until the very last few
weeks of the semester before the outline
I think that's a horrible mistake
if you outline every single weekend you
synthesize all of the substantive lawyer
your notes with your commercial outlines
and you put it into a form that you
understand you get that work done ahead
of time it gives you so much more time
at the end of the semester to do
practice exams to to memorize the
black-letter law that you're going to
use on the final exams it's a huge
advantage that saves you a huge amount
of time and creates more study time at
the end of the semester tip number five
take a course on law school essays there
are clear strategies for issue spotting
exams that you can use on any class
whether it's an exam for contracts or
con law or torts or whatever standard
strategies will work on any issue
spotting exam legal eagle has a course
and there are others out there that are
also very good it saves you a huge
amount of time because you can learn to
take law school essays yourself but you
have to take a number of
practice exams and often professors only
give you so many practice exams so it
can save you a huge amount of time to
learn the strategies upfront so you
don't have to brute-force your way
through a huge number of practice exams
because they take hours and hours to get
through every single practice exam if
you learn the strategies and start
taking practice exams at least halfway
through the semester long before
everyone else starts taking practice
exams you will be miles ahead by the
time the study period rolls around and
you will save a huge amount of time
before you have to take your first final
exam so remember you can learn the
strategies that go into an issue
spotting exam in the same way that you
learn the strategies for reading
comprehension and logic games in LSAT
and if you learn those strategies and
you start taking practice exams sooner
it will save you a huge amount of time
and you will be ready for your final
exams much earlier than everybody else
and when you're graded on a curve that's
what matters being better than everybody
else so if you liked this video please
click like and subscribe for more law
school crushing tips and also please
download our checklists that will help
you hack your way through law school and
save a huge amount of time so thanks for
stopping by from everyone here at legal
eagle
[Music]